turning now to a very important story
about health care costs and how two
similar surgeries ended up with two very
different bills for one seattle man his
name is eli bear he had related jaw
surgeries at the same hospital under the
same insurance provider now bearer
thought that would mean similar medical
costs but he was oh so wrong his bill
for the second procedure was nearly
listen to this ten times higher yep ten
times we're looking at the story as part
of our continuing bill of the month
partnership with kaiser health news and
npr
i had migraines i would say almost
weekly eli bear had severe jaw pain
until he underwent a two-part surgery to
realign his mouth pallet he had premera
health insurance through his job that
covered most of the first surgery on his
upper jaw in 2018 and he paid three
thousand dollars out of pocket
bear switched jobs before his second
surgery on his lower jaw in 2020 but
still had premier health insurance and
did the procedure at the same hospital
after the second surgery that really
fixed everything my migraines were gone
and then the bills came
this time bear's out-of-pocket expenses
totaled more than 27 thousand dollars he
learned that having the same insurance
provider did not mean the same coverage
when he changed jobs and his new plan
had a five thousand dollar lifetime
limit policy for jaw surgery i was
speechless because i had never heard of
that i had a little mini breakdown the
amount
was pretty devastating
after bear filed a complaint with the
state attorney general's office the
hospital lowered his bill to about seven
thousand dollars
bear is now paying that balance but he
feels blindsided i feel like i have a
lot of distrust in
hospitals and the insurance industry i
just feel like
the process is too confusing and you
know could wind up devastating if you
get a surprise bill
now premier insurance did not respond to
our request for comment but in a
statement to kaiser health news it said
this that the plan details are available
online and it highly recommends members
to contact them to verify the benefits
the swedish hospital told cbs news that
bear was billed for the care that he
received however the surgeon advocated
to get the bill lowered since the
patient and the provider were not aware
of the lifetime limit before his surgery
joining us now is dr elizabeth rosenthal
she's the editor-in-chief of kaiser
health news good to see you dr rosenthal
can you explain this insurance policy
issue that that eli was relying on
oh yeah you know one of the wonderful
things the affordable care act did was
to impose lifetime limits in 10
essential categories but jaw surgery is
not one of them and it's in this gray
area between health insurance and
medical insurance and that's where eli
got trapped the other thing is so many
of us assume that when we see the same
name on our insurance card the policies
will work the same but what benefits you
get from any one insurance depends
largely on what your employer decides to
give you so in switching employers he
had the same looking insurance card but
the benefits were hugely different it
always seems so complicated to me that
so what can people do before and after
the surgery to avoid this happening to
them
or is there anything you can do
are you frozen
she lost her oh well i think one thing
that's really important for people
go ahead go ahead one thing that's
really important for people to know is
um you know you if you ask your doctor
is this going to be covered you know
they want it to be covered so they're
going to say sure which should be
covered by your insurance but as eli
discovered this was um on an 80-page
booklet so his doctor didn't know so
it's really important to contact your
insurer to verify those benefits the
second thing is if you don't get redress
and you get the surprise bill
you know good for eli go to your state
attorney general or your state consumer
protection
consumer protection board they may be
able to help and your doctor may be able
to help you know patients and doctors
shouldn't have to read 80 page booklets
in the fine print to just to know if
their essential surgery is going to be
covered or not you know dr elizabeth
rosenthal those 80 page booklets will
get you every single time
i don't know anybody who's reading that
stuff thank you though thank you very
much even though i know we should thank
you